bienvenidos a forward el forma
detrás de esta explotación que se dice
vanguardista se encuentra bayern el
gigante de los pesticidas a escasos 30
minutos en carro desde bruselas es un
lugar de lobo ideal todos los meses
vemos productos que desaparecen del
mercado la visita comienza con una
presentación detallada sobre las
ventajas de los productos agroquímicos
son muy útiles para alcanzar una
producción sostenible durante los
últimos 50 años con las nuevas
tecnologías fuimos capaces de producir
la misma cantidad de alimentos con 68
por ciento menos de tierra pero desde
hace unos 20 años la unión europea
prohibió el uso de cientos de pesticidas
en su territorio resultado los
fabricantes buscan alternativas aquí por
ejemplo cómo encontrar un reemplazo para
el antiguos ipc una molécula usada en su
momento para impedir la germinación de
las papas
vemos que en el mundo la legislación no
se interpreta de la misma manera los
mismos productos que están autorizados
por ejemplo en japón canadá o eeuu
en europa la lejía
es muy prudente y siempre se acomoda del
lado de la seguridad y acude ante todo
al principio de precaución garantizando
que si no se está seguro al cien por
cien de poder evitar los riesgos o no se
autoriza
la web
una legislación estricta que las
industrias logran evadir exportando los
productos prohibidos afuera de la unión
europea una práctica difícil de
justificar
no es como si no estuviese regulado
estos productos deben ser declarados a
las autoridades legales si decidimos que
exportarlos no es como si un país
pudiese exportar lo que quisiera sin
declarar debemos declarar lo que es
cuando y hacia qué país es un proceso
totalmente transparente pero no es fácil
de explicar es verdad
en helsinki finlandia esa es la agencia
europea encargada de velar por la
transparencia de este proceso las
exportaciones de productos prohibidos en
el bloque comunitario deben ser objeto
de una notificación validada por los
equipos de jamil efe
su vocación es entregar informaciones
sobre esta sustancia o esta mezcla en
especial las propiedades y luego la
manera en la que esta sustancia está
regulada en europa un documento que
pretende informar al país importador
sobre las razones de la prohibición en
la unión europea en seguida los
productos psoe salen hacia brasil
ucrania marruecos o eeuu recientemente
un estudio reveló la magnitud de este
comercio en 2018 80.000 toneladas de
pesticidas prohibidos fueron exportados
a fuera del territorio de la unión los
principales destinos de los pesticidas
prohibidos male in europe
son también los principales países desde
los cuales europa importa alimentos y
productos agrícolas
entonces en efecto estos pesticidas
regresan a europa en forma de residuos
en los alimentos que los consumidores
europeos encuentran en sus platos
una práctica que la comisión europea
quisiera terminar
tenemos que ser coherentes y cambiar
este enfoque creo que no es normal ya no
podemos justificar el hecho de poner en
riesgo la salud y el medio ambiente de
los demás fuera de la unión con
productos que no queremos usar en la
unión europea
ahora falta ver si los estados miembros
acompañan esta propuesta de la comisión
europea por el momento sólo francia
prevé la prohibición de estas
exportaciones para 2022
pero para el lobby de los pesticidas en
bruselas estas leyes no podrán impedir
el comercio de estos productos
y está claro que si mañana se prohibiera
la producción y exportación de estos
productos en europa estos productos
serían producidos en otro lugar el hecho
de que europa decida prohibir sus
exportaciones no quiere decir que estos
productos no serán producidos
simplemente porque hay otros países en
el mundo que los han autorizado
para 4 cyan amiga atrás zinc a estos
productos considerados como peligrosos
en territorio europeo siguen siendo
utilizados masivamente fuera de la unión
europea